welcome to this tutorial we're going to
build a Tetris game we'd react and the
first question you should ask yourself
is is react a good choice for making a
game like this and to be honest I don't
know it is probably better to build it
with vanilla JavaScript but I wanted to
do this for myself to test how this game
can work out with react and sometimes
I'll do these kind of products just to
yeah kind of expand my knowledge and try
things out and the idea for this started
when I was looking at the tutorial at
YouTube where this guy creates a Tetris
game with vanilla JavaScript and it's in
this channel that's called meth meth
method and yeah you can think whatever
you thought of that name the tutorial is
really good actually and I learned a lot
because I have to say this I'm not a
game maker I create web applications and
stuff like that and web pages so I'm
kind of a rookie in the game development
it was fun to create this game we'd
react and see how it works and in this
video he used canvas I'm not going to
use canvas I'm using regular divs and a
grid for this one because I wanted to
try that out also and not use canvas and
it's also good to see how good react
performs cause there's going to be a lot
of divs that we render to the screen
because each cell in the Tetris game is
Adam and I'm also going to borrow some
of the code here and especially the one
where we're going to check for collision
when we rotate our tetromino that is the
name of the blocks in Tetris big credits
to this channel math math method and the
video where this guy shows how to create
a Tetris game in just I think it's 50
minutes or so yeah and it's a really
good tutorial if you want to learn how
to build a Tetris in plain JavaScript
alright let's get to the app then and
here's the tetris game that we're going
to build our shoes to have kind of a
retro style to it with this stores in
the background this is just an image I
found on unsplash and we're going to
show the score at the rows and the level
and then we have a start button so if we
press Start again we can
play the game and we're using the arrow
keys on the keyboard for this one you
rotate the Tetra minor with up arrow and
you kind of go left and right with other
arrows and down will make it go faster
down there and there will be some
limitation in this game because this is
not a perfect Tetris game for example
the key input we're just using the
regular repeat here when holding down
the down arrow key there should probably
be a better function for this where we
can control the speed of this one and
also I will be using an interval for
this one we could also use
requestanimationframe where we can
create kind of a more controlled
animation so it will not be a perfect
Tetris game but it will be a good
practice in react and especially react
hooks that so many people are talking
about now on the Internet so we will be
creating custom hooks and we will use
state we will use use effect and use
callback and also we're going to use
react memo for minimizing or rear-end us
of the cells so I think this will be a
good practice in react and especially
react hooks so let's get to it we will
start creating the game in the next
video
we're going to start to build our tetris
game now and we're going to use create
react app and I actually use that one a
lot cause it's great for bootstrapping
your project and don't have to set up
your web pack and Babel config and
everything like that from scratch so I
highly recommend you use create react
app it's great and we create a project
by go into our console in my case I'm
using hyper and we just type npx create
- react - app and we can cool our
application react - Tetris this will
create the folder that called react -
Tetris and then press Enter and then we
just wait it will take a second here
alright we're good to go here and it's
important now that you navigate into the
new project folder you created so type
CD react - Tetris and if we list the
files you can see it has created some
folders and files for us here and now
I'm using style components for this game
so we have to install that one also and
we do that by typing NPM I styled -
components all right some arrows here
but I think we'll be fine it's just on
my computer I can clear the console I
have also included some files in the
starter files that you have to copy to
your project folder otherwise it won't
work so make sure first of all that you
download the starter files it's on
github and the link should be provided
to you and then in the starter files you
have something that's called BD dot PNG
that's the background image that the
Stars you see here then we have deformed
that's called pixel I found this one on
the internet it should be free to use so
I hope it is and we have something
that's called use in the world of chaos
and that's a custom hook that's created
by Dan Abramov that I'm going to use
when we create a game loop with the
JavaScript interval so we just have to
copy this one over and I'll explain it
later in the tutorial first grab the BD
dot PNG file copy that one and go into
your
direct folder and inside SRC the source
folder we create a new folder that's
called
I am deed and that's for image of course
and you can just paste the background in
there all right then we have the font so
grab that one copy that one and create
another folder inside of your SRC your
source folder and we can call this
folder font go inside of there and paste
the font inside of it and then we have
the use in the world of J's file so copy
that one and still in the SRC folder
create another folder that's called
hooks this is the folder where we're
going to create our custom hooks so go
inside of that folder and paste the use
in the hojae's file and this should be
it this is everything we need to get us
started so in the next video we'll start
to scaffold out some components and
we'll continue with our application
the first thing I do when I create the
react application is that I scaffold out
all the components that I need and
that's what we're going to be doing in
this video so first of all you can see
that we have a lot of files here that
was created for us with create react app
and we're not going to use some of this
stuff here you can yeah you can delete
it if you want the logo the
serviceworker the app test and stuff
like that or you can just let it be
because we're not using it now we are
going to use the app dot JS file here
and index dot JS file for now and the
index dot J's file we don't actually
have to touch that one we can just go
inside the app dot J's file we can
delete everything inside of there so as
usual or application is going to start
in the app dot JS file this is kind of
the highest component in the hierarchy
so we import react from react we import
Tetris from dot forward slash components
forward slash Tetris right so and of
course this one we haven't created this
one yet
so we're going to create that in a
minute and we create our app function I
like to use arrow functions for this one
you can use a regular function if you
want to do that but we have con stab
equals parenthesis and we're going to
create an explicit return for this one
so we just need parenthesis then we can
create a div with a class name of app
and we have our tetris components like
so and then we export default app and
that's our app component then we can
create a new folder inside our SRC
folder that's called components inside
the components folder we are going to
create five different components so you
can just create the file names now so we
create one that's called cell das make
sure you have a capital letter here to
start with or yeah maybe you don't name
your components like that but I like to
name them with capital
because it's a component so we create
another file that's called display doc
das and we have a new file that called
stage das and we have a new file that's
called start button das
and the last one is going to be the
tetris doc yes file all right these are
our five components the tetris dot JS
file is kind of the heart of this
application we can go into our cell dot
JS file and start scaffold out this
component so we import reacts from react
as usual and we create the component
cost cell equals two parentheses and we
are going to have props for this one so
we can create these ones also Ida
structure the mouth we don't have a type
for this one and we talked about this
later on we make an implicit return for
now and we can just have a div and yeah
right cell inside of it and we export
default cell like so so we say that one
and then we have our display dot JS file
we import react from react we have a
Const that's called display equals and
for this one we're going to have two
props so we destructor them out one is
called game over and one is called text
and we create a div inside of here where
we're going to have the text we create
curly braces and text so grab that prop
and display it inside of the deal export
default display we will style these
components later with style components
so we will change some stuff inside of
them we just scaffold them out now so we
know what components we're going to have
this game save that one then we go into
stage 2 ts file we import react from
react of course you can copy and paste a
lot here also if you want to do that for
this one
going to import the cell component so we
import cell from dot forward slash cell
and then we create a Const stage equals
two and with the structure to prop that
we're going to have that's called stage
and we make an implicit return for this
one also and as you can see I'm not
doing any prop type checking for this
course you can add that in yourself if
you want to do that to verify your props
with prop types all right we create a
div for now again an inside here we're
going to map through our stage prop and
create cells from this stage prop and
we're going to do that later also so it
can just have a cell for now inside of
this and we export default stage like so
and we save this one then we have our
start button dot JS file so we import
react from react and we have a cost
start button and we have a prop that's
going to be pull back for this one and
we make an implicit return with a div
that says start game and we export
default start button like so we say that
one and then it's the last one it's our
tetris component or heart of this
application so we import react from
react like so and then we're going to
have some components here we import our
stage from dot forward slash stage we're
also going to need or display from dot
forward slash display and we import or
start button from dot forward slash
start button and these ones we can check
them
here this is obviously going to be the
stage with the cells in it and these are
the display components we have three of
them and this is the start game button
here so these are the ones we'll create
and now they'll recreate our post Tetris
and equals to an error function and we
have curly braces for this one because
we're going to have more logic inside of
here and we can create the return
statement here first we have a kind of a
rapid Eve here and as I said we're going
to rename these ones when we style the
components then we have our stage and
for now we're not sending in any prop
because we don't have anything to send
in to it right now
then we can create an aside element
that's obviously the sidebar here that
we're creating and then we're going to
have three different displays now for
these ones we have a text prop and for
now they can just say score you can copy
this one and paste two times and this
one can say rose and level all right you
can also wrap these ones inside of a div
and end it like that and below we're
going to have our start button and it's
going to get a callback prop but we
don't have that yet either so we're not
giving it that now so this is it and we
export default Tetris like so okay then
we can store this up to see what we've
got
so NPM start and we have all our
components showing up here and that's
great they are of course not styled yet
but we're going to do that soon first we
have to create the stage and or tetra-
and we're going to do that in the next
video before we do the styling so we can
see the UI here
okay we're going to create the stage and
the tetra-
in this video and to do that we have to
create a couple of new files inside our
source folder or SRC folder we can
create a new file that's called game
helpers ojs and that's a lowercase G on
that one because this is not a component
and we can also create a new file that's
called tetra- ojs make sure you're
inside a game helper cas file here we're
going to create a stage and we are going
to have two costs where we can set the
stage width and height and we have to
import these ones into our components so
we have to export them from this file so
we export cost and then with capital
letters we can have stage width and we
can set that one to twelve and we export
Const stage height and we set that to 20
so that's our width and height but we
actually need a function that creates
the stage for us and the stage is going
to be a nested array a multi-dimensional
array that represents rows and columns
and we have to export this function that
creates the stage also cause we're going
to need it in our components so we
export cost create stage and it is an
error function alright so how is this
going to work well we're going to create
a multi-dimensional array that
represents the grid so we create an
array from something and that something
is another array that we're going to
create from the stage height and this is
going to be an empty array so it's not
going to be useful for us so we have to
do something where to fill this up with
something we can do that by supplying an
inline function here and that means for
each row we create a new array from the
stage width and we're going to fill it
with another array there's a lot of a
race here and for now we set it to zero
and we have something that's called
clear and these ones I'm going to
explain it later on zero equals nothing
on the grid we have the different tetra-
each of them going to have a letter here
so we know that the grid has that
tetromino
in that particular cell and we also have
this clear property here that it's going
to be set to merge when we have a
tetromino merge into the stage that
means when we have collided so the
tetra- should stay in the stage and not
be cleared in the next render and as I
said I will explain this later on so I
hope you understand this function what
it's doing we're creating a new array
from an array that we're creating here
with a States height that's the 20 rows
we're going to have in our grid and
we're supplying an inline function that
for each row create a new array with our
cells and we're filling them up with
this array here that has one value that
is 0 and that's represent a clean cell
there's nothing in that cell on the
stage and we also have this string here
that says clear for now and that means
that there's no tetra minor that has
collided in this cell and we should wipe
it out from the stage in the next render
okay so that's how we create our stage
and if you remember up here in the
components we had our stage here and we
had our prop that's called stage and
this is the stage we're sending in from
the Tetris component so we can actually
import this one here in the Tetris dot
J's file we can import our create stage
function here and we grabbed it from dot
dot forward slash game help us like so
and for now we can just send it into
this one we have the stage prop equals
curly braces create stage and
parentheses because we invoke this
function here just checking so we're not
breaking anything here now and we going
to
this later on because we're going to
have the stage in a custom hook and a
state for this one but for now we can
just send it in so it renders something
inside a stage component you can remove
this one and inside the div here we
create the curly braces because we're
going to use JavaScript now and map over
our stage prop so we have a row and we
also map through that row and then we
get our cell and or X value for that one
so what are we doing here
well we have the stage that's the one we
created we map through that and when we
map through that stage array we get the
row and each row is also an array that
holds the cells so we map through that
row also and we get the cell so for each
cell we are going to render out the cell
component we can set the key to X and
our type are going to be the first value
in the cell array and that's the one we
created down here we're telling it when
we initially do the render we're telling
it that this stage is clean we don't
have any tetromino in the stage so we
grabbing this value here and that's a
serie that we set it to initially go
back into your stage component we have
to close this one also this one should
hopefully render out the stage for us
but as you can see we didn't style it
yet so it's just a lot of cells here in
one column but we're going to fix that
when we do the styling later on alright
let's get back to our code that's our
stage now we have to create our tetra-
and we're going to keep them in a Const
that's called tetra-
and it's going to be an object so we
export Const capital letter tetra-
equals an object and we're going to have
different properties with these ones
first we can create a property that's
called syrup because I'm going to use
this initially when we store
the application we don't want to show a
tetromino on the stage but you could do
it some other way of course but I think
it's nice to have it inside of these
tetra- object alright so we create an
object we're going to have a property
that's called shape and the shape is
also going to be an array with a race I
noticed that there's a lot of a race
with a race when you create games like
this so we have an array then we have
another array and we just set it to zero
and then we have another property that's
called color and this is just going to
be a string 0 comma 0 comma 0 like that
so that's our clean cell that's what
we're using when we're not showing any
tetromino and then we have seven
different tetra- we have the I DLL st
and said so we can't start by creating
the I so we create a new property that's
called I and we create a new object for
that one we have the shaped property
that's going to be an array and inside
of that array we're going to have
another array and as I mentioned before
zero equals nothing on the grid and
we're going to use a letter where we
want to show these tetra- first we have
a zero that's nothing and we have a
string with a capital I then we have a
zero and the zero then we create another
array with another zero and another I
and a zero and the zero and this one is
just going to be a four by four so we
can copy this one and paste them in like
that and as you can see these
going to be the eye shape that is the
long one the long turtle minor that's
the only one that has four in width and
we can make it a little cleaner here
maybe I will not auto format is because
it will destroy this formatting I've
done here it's easier to see the
tetromino here otherwise it will format
it in just one line for me and that's no
good so we have another property here
also so we have the color and this is
yet again a string and this is just an
RGB value I'm going to use in the CSS
later on so I'm setting the color for
this one - 82 - 7 - 3 0 so this is the
eye we have here well I guess we can
just copy and paste this one make sure
you make a coma deer and we create a J
and a shape for the day is going to be
we can remove these last ones because
it's going to be three by three so we
remove the last row there also change
this once - j j day and we're going to
have a j there also i hope you see this
oops it's going to be string i hope you
see this pattern here that this is a j
and the color for this one is going to
be 36 95 - two three all right then we
copy this one and paste we're going to
create the L shape and it's exactly like
the J but we change this one and put it
there instead and of course we should
have an L also as a value in these
streams and the Cora is going to be two
to three one seven three and thirty six
all right we copy this
1 make sure you don't forget that coma
dear and we're going to create the shape
and this is actually just going to be
two values in so we have the Oh Oh like
so and oh so we have a 2 by 2 array
there and the color for this one is
going to be 2 2 3 2 1 7 and also 36 for
that one alright then we can grab the El
up here copy it
make another coma paste it we have the S
shape and it's going to be a 0 and s
don't forget that this is a string here
so don't forget the ticks here and then
we have an S and an S and a 0 and these
ones are just going to be zeros like so
and the color is 48 2 1 1 and 56
alright then we paste in yet another one
and we have two to go we have the T and
that shape is going to be 0 0 0 then we
have a tea a tea and tea and now have a
serie a tea and a serum a nice little
shaped tea there and the curious one
hundred thirty to sixty one and 198 and
we have the last one and that's the said
whoa kind of boring this but we have to
do it otherwise we don't have any tip
from - alright the set
we have a said asset and a zero then we
have a zero said an asset and then zero
zero and zero and then we just have the
color for this one and that's two two
seven seventy eight and seventy eight
all right so that's our tetra-
and we have one more thing to do because
we want to have a function that
generates a random tetromino for us so
we export cost random kept roam I know
and we create the function for that one
we have curly braces here so first we
create the cost called tetriminos
lowercase letters and we create the
string with capital letters IDL OST set
and this is of course the string with
all our seven tetriminos now we create
another cost ran the tetra minor like so
we're going to grab a random letter from
this tetra - string and we do that by
typing tetra - that's the string Const
and inside of here we do a little math
dot floor math dot random times tetra -
length like so and this is just a
standard for generating random numbers
of the length of this in this case the
string so where the string length and
we're getting a random number for this
one and I misspelled this one it should
be tetra - yeah so we have the tetra -
string and we grabbing a random number
for that one and that will return one of
the letters for us and that's how we get
to random tetromino because now
we can return from or tetra-
Rand tetromino so for example let's say
that this will give us an L here so we
have that one and we go to our tetra-
object and we have an L here and that
will of course grab the L property for
us and return this one here the L
tetromino
with the shape and the color this is an
object here so we get that object back
and that's how we get a random tetromino
type the serie here it should have cost
beyond oh there and say this one all
right this was a lot I know I know and I
think that's why I don't do games but I
recommend it to really go through this
code and try to understand it as much as
possible before moving forward in the
next video we're going to create the
styles with style component and after
that we're actually going to start to do
some heavy coding on the game we're
going to do some styling now to get this
sad look out of this Tetris game and if
you're not a CSS person you don't like
the style things you can just copy and
paste the styles from the starter files
into your project but you have to import
them into your component as I'm going to
show in this video and also change your
divs to the components that we using
from the styled component I'm going to
show you this soon so let's get on with
it
first of all we're going to create the
global styling and actually I've been
trying to lace you for this one because
you can't create global stars with style
components but I'm actually just going
to use this index dot CSS file that's
yeah premade for us with great react app
and it's imported in the index file and
that's because we're going to have a
font and it's a little bit more
troublesome to import it with star
components so if we go inside index dot
CSS file first we're going to set or
body we're going to set our margin to
zero and then we are going to import a
font so we have a font face and
firmly is going to be call the pixel and
we have a source SRC with or URL and we
grab or font from font forward slash
pixel - LCD - seven dot both we can also
set the format to both like so and we
say that one yeah and we will not see
anything happening here right now but
that's our global styling then we can
move up to our components and we're
going to style the tetris component
first and what I like to do when I use
star component is that I create this
folder that where I place all of my
styling and then I import them into the
components so inside of the components
folder create another folder that's
called styles and inside a Styles folder
create a new file and call it style
Celsius I also like to name them like
this with styled and then the component
name and ojs so styled Celsius capital s
capital C and first we have to import
style from style components and then we
need to export or style component
because we're going to import it into
the Tetris component when we created
this one so export comes to style sell
an equals style dot and this is going to
be a diva
we have backticks because this is a tag
function and this is how style
components works you have this tag
function and you can write regular CSS
inside of it and if you don't know style
components I really recommend you to
read more about it at their webpage I'm
not going to go through everything with
star components in this tutorial cause
as I said before this tutorial is about
showing you how to build a Tetris game
we'd react and I assume that you know
some stuff with react and yeah star
components also otherwise it's not that
difficult to use star components so I
think you will pick up a lot just
watching me create these come
opponents all right and I just realized
I created the styled cell now okay
I said Tetris component but it's the
styled cell I create a null so well
let's create the styles for the cell
component first done okay we're going to
have a width and set that to auto then
we're going to set our background and
that's going to be an RGB a and we're
going to grab this from the props that
we send me into the cell component so
for now I just type this out and we go
to the cell component and I'm going to
show you how these prop work so we have
a dollar sign curly braces and props and
an arrow function and a props we have
one that's called
color so that's how we get our RGB value
and we set the Alpha value to 0.7 this
is just regular CSS so we're going to
come back to this in a second but first
we save this one and we go into the cell
component and I'm going to show you how
this works with the props so first of
all we import or styled cell that's the
one we created and we grabbed it from
Styles forward slash styled cell like so
then we also going to need or tetra- so
we import or tetriminos if you remember
that's the one we created down here it's
an object with different tetra- so we
grab that from dot dot forward slash
tetrominoes alright so now we got
everything we want in this component we
can now first change this one to our
styled cell that's the one we create
here and we import it in this component
here so we use it here you could write
the style component inside of this
component and many people do it like
that but I like to have them separated
because I think this is yeah I like this
structure of things so you can do
whatever you want and
don't have to do all this export and
import stuff that I do here okay so this
style sell is going to have a type prop
and we grab the type from type we are
sending that in here and now we're
passing that prop in through our style
component and now we're going to have a
color and the color we can grab from the
tetra- and the type is going to be the
tetra- so we if we for example have the
type of L it will grab the tetra- L for
the color and of course we're also going
to grab the property color because when
we created the tetra-
we have both a shape property and the
color property so this is the one we're
grabbing here is the color property from
the tetra- all right so for now we can
just we change this one yeah we can say
on L because we're not sending in
anything to this component yet because
as I said I intended to do the tetris
first but now we do the sell here
instead and as you can see now we're
getting the color here but it will color
everything here and that's because this
cell row you see it's the commit take up
the complete weed here so the color is
there but we haven't created a grid yet
and that's because it's showing all
yellow now because each cell is a
hundred percent with right now alright
let's go back to the styling we need
some shadows on or tetra- so this is
also how it works with props that you
send into your style components you can
grab them with an inline function like
this because this is a tag function you
can use a dollar sign and curly brackets
and use expressions inside of these ones
and by using this inline function we can
grab the props that we send into our
style components and we had one prop
that is called color so we're grabbing
that one inside of here all right so
that's our
background we also want to set our
border yet again we have a dollar sign
and curly braces we have our props and
then we're going to do a ternary
operator here we check if or props type
if that one equals to 0 that means we
not have a tetromino in this specific
cell so we don't want to have a border
so we set that one to null pixels solid
I don't actually yeah I don't think we
need solid here but yeah let it be there
for now otherwise we set it to 4 pixels
solid all right then we have our border
bottom color and that is going to be on
our DBA and yet again we have a dollar
sign curly braces we have our props and
we have our props color and we're going
to set the Alpha value here to zero two
point one we can actually just grab this
one and copy and paste it in three times
because now we have border right color
and that one we're going to set to one
and then we have border top color
one also for the left color and we set
that one to zero point three and this
will give us kind of this shadow effect
on the blocks yeah if you don't like
them you can just play around with these
and set your own shadow and this is also
what I liked about star components
because you can send lien props like
this we can easily modify or CSS
conditionally with props and that's
really nice actually so what I'm doing
here I'm just using the same color value
as we set in the tetra- object but I'm
just changing the Alpha value to get
different opacity on the blocks all
right let's go to our tetris das file
now and do it in the right order here we
are going to create two different style
component
here we have one that style tetris
rapper and one that's called style
tetris so we have a wrapper around here
and we have the tetris also we can
actually just type them out here so we
can see the structure or it's here it's
going to be a styled tetris wrapper like
so and we close it down below there and
it will complain our course we haven't
created this one yet and then below
we're going to have the styled tetris
component and of course we have to move
that down here like so and I will
explain later why we have this wrapper
here so these are the two star
components so let's create a new file
inside of the Styles folder that's
called styled Tetris yes and inside that
file inside style Tetris dot yes imports
start from style components like so we
also need to import our background image
so we can call it BD image and we grab
that from dot dot forward slash dot
forward slash I am D V J dot PNG like so
then we export Const or styled Tetris
wrapper and that one is going to be a
styled dot TV and we have our backticks
because this is a tag function we set a
width 200 viewport width and our height
200 view put height yeah this is just
regular CSS now and I'm not going to
explain the CSS here either I hope you
know your CSS otherwise you can pick up
some things here but I won't explain
them yeah in detail and here we can set
our background with a URL and now we can
just use or BJ image and we do that by
creating a dollar sign and code
basis and inside we have obedia image we
can set a default color to zero zero
zero we have a background size cover and
overflow is going to be hidden for this
one and this is also great with star
components cause otherwise if you set a
background image you may have done some
inline styling to get the image to show
up as a background image but here we can
just import it and use it in the star
component like this so we don't have to
do any inline styling on the component
itself alright then we have our export
calls to style Tetris and that's going
to be a style deve also type function
this is going to be a flex we align
items to flex start we set our pairing
to 40 pixels and we have a Morgan of
zero and auto and a max width of 900
pixels the CSS here is not really
optimized you can try to get a better
look for yourself if you want to do that
I haven't put that much time in the CSS
styling I just wanted something to work
fairly good so you could probably
improve the CSS and get a better grid
and stuff like that
and inside here we have our aside and
we're going to style that and this is
also great with star components cause
you can nest them inside of here just
like you do in sass for example so we
set up with 200% max width of 200 pixels
we set our display to block and padding
to 0 and 20 pixels like so and that is
going to be our star component for the
style Tetris no we just have to import
it up in the component so we can import
or star
tetris rapper and/or style tetris and we
grabbed him from dot forward slash
styles forward slash style tetris and
now it shouldn't complain here no
alright and as you can see we are
gradually changing this one to something
else we see the space here now and we
see that the cells are just yeah this
tiny bits no alright then we can create
another style inside our Styles folder
that's called style stage das and we
create the style first so we import
style from style components then we
export Const styled stage and it's equal
a style div and we have backticks cause
it's a tagged function and we're going
to display a grid for this one we have a
grid template rose it's going to repeat
we grabbing from props or props dot
height a coma and then we're going to do
some CSS calculation here we have 25
viewport width and we divide it with we
have dollar sign and curly braces cause
now we're going to have another inline
function another inline function to grab
our props and we grab the props dot
width and this is going to do some nice
little calculation for us to make the
grid look nice and we are doing this to
keep the aspect ratio of the grid cells
then we have our grid template columns
that's also going to repeat and from our
props yet again we grab our prop start
with and it's going to be one fragment
and of course that one should be there
like so these calculations is because we
want to keep the aspect ratio of our
cells we want them to be perfect squares
all the time and this is actually kind
of tricky to do so yeah I've got it to
work yeah fairly responsive but not 100%
so if you come up with a better idea
feel free to change it to whatever you
want we want to have a grid gap of one
pixel and the border going to be two
pixels solid and we can set it to 3 3 3
we have a width of 100% and max width of
25 viewport width and a background of
say 1 1 1 all right so that's our styled
stage we just have to import it into the
stage component so make sure you inside
the stage component an import styled
stage from dot forward slash styles
forward slash style
all right and then we rename this one to
our styled stage we close it with the
same and we're going to send some props
inside of this course we had a width and
that one we're grabbing from we are
sending in the stage as props to this
one so if we grab the stage and the
first row and the length we know the
width of our grid and the height we just
grab the stage lengths like so and that
will give us the height from our
multi-dimensional array all right we
save this one and see what we've got and
as you can see we have something here so
we're slowly getting there we can
actually now also go back into the cell
component and we can remove the text
here we don't need that one and that's
why we can just self close it like this
and that will get us our grid and here
you can
see the shadows that we created in the
cell component and it works fairly
responsive what have we got left to do
we go into style or display and or start
button inside our Styles folder create a
new file style display dot yes and
import styled from styled components and
we export const styled display and it
equals a style div and yet again
backticks box-sizing to border box we
display flex we align items to Center
why I'm using flexbox is to align the
text in the different displays we have a
margin of 0 0 or 20 pixels and 0 we have
a padding of 20 pixels we have a border
of 4 pixels solid and a triple 3 we have
a min height of 30 pixels we have a
width of 100% a border radius of 20
pixels and the color and that's why
we're grabbing from props yet again we
have a dollar sign and curly braces we
have our props and we do a ternary
operator cause we are using the same
display component when we did play game
over as we display the score and rows
and things like that so we have a prop
that's called game over and if it's game
over we set the text to read otherwise
we set it to some grace
we set the background to black we have a
font family of pixel that's the one we
imported in the global CSS file we can
sell it yeah some fallback fonts here
and the font size of 0.8 RM like so and
then we just have to import and use it
in our display component so we import a
styled display from dot forward slash
Styles forward slash style display and
then we change this div to our style
display component and we also had our
prop that's called game over so we send
that one in like so and let's see what
we've got
and there's our nice displace and we
have this retro formed inside of them
and that's good we just have to style a
start button and then I think we'll be
good to go
to do some heavy coding on this game so
inside our Styles create a new file and
call it style Start button dog guess
import style from style components whoo
getting boring boring boring but we have
to do this so we export a Const and
style Start button and we have a styled
button double backticks and inside we
write or CSS we have our box sizing and
we set that one to border box we have a
Morgan of 0 0 of 20 pixels on 0 we have
a padding of 20 pixels a min height of
30 pixels of width of hundred-percent
and a border radius of 20 pixels of
border we set that one to none we have a
color of white background
for a triple three we have a formed
family of pixel and some fallback fonts
we have a font size of 1 RM an outline
of none because we don't want to display
that ugly outline when we press the
button we set the cursor to pointer also
and we say that one an inside or start
button we are going to import this one
so we import style start button from dot
forward slash Styles forward slash style
start button and of course we change
this one to style the start button we
are also going to have an on click
Handler on this one so we can type it in
now so we have the own click and it's
going to be a call back alright so
that's the start button and it's showing
nicely but nothing is happening now
because we don't have that callback
created yet but we have something that
looks like a Tetris we're just going to
remove this yellow one from our cell
because the type is going to be the type
and here we also change that one to type
because that was only to show you what
we were doing here and as you can see
now we have our grid here instead and
that's nice cause that's our playing
field and everything set up for us so we
can start coding the real game here and
we'll start with that in the next video
so see you then
okay we got our stage or displays and/or
start button and it's time to code some
logic for this game and how is it going
to work yeah well we're going to have
this stage of course with the cells here
and we're going to have a player and
we're going to use react hooks to create
this game and two big advantages with
hooks is that you can abstract them and
you can reduce them and compose things
together and that's really great and for
this game we're going to create three
own custom hooks and that's the use
stage use player use game status and the
use interval is the one that Danna
remote created for us and the reason
that I created these custom hooks is
that I want to kind of separate out the
logic for different things so we have
all the logic for the player in the use
player hook and we have all the logic
for the stage in the use stage hook and
we also have the use game status that is
going to have yeah mostly the display
logic that we're going to show like the
scores and things like that and how many
rows we cleared so that is how we're
going to divide up the code and we have
the tetris component that's going to be
our main component as I said before
that's the part of our application and
as we creating a game we're going to
have some kind of game loop and as I
also said before we're going to use an
interval for this one and not using yeah
maybe the more sophisticated way where
you get animation frames and stuff like
that so we have this grid here that is
represented by the array and we can
actually console.log this one out so we
can see what we have in our array so
inside of here somewhere
we can console.log create stage like so
and I'm just going to show the console
here and as you can see we have an array
with twenty rows in it and each row has
twelve cells and as you can see here we
have a seer and that means that this
cell is clear we don't have a tetromino
in this cell and it's also set to clear
as you can see now we just have a clean
stage here so everyone here is clear and
that means that we don't have any
tetromino merge interest
because when we collide with something
we're going to change this one to merge
and in the next render we're going to
keep every cell that has merged here and
that's the way we keep the tetra- that
has collided I think it will get to much
more clearer when we actually create the
tetromino and how our game loop works
because the game loop are going to do a
couple of thing for us the first thing
we have to do in our game loop is that
we clear the stage and then we check for
any merged cells here and we don't clear
the merged ones so they are going to
stay in the stage they're going to stay
in the array for a stage and then we're
going to check the position over
tetromino and if it hasn't collided we
are just going to set it to clear again
and that means for the next render it's
going to be wiped out and it's going to
move and that's the way we get the
illusion of movement here or maybe it's
not an illusion it is a movement but the
tetromino that hasn't collided is
getting cleared on every render but if
we have set this to merge it's going to
stay in the stage and then we do this
over and over again with our interval
and that's the way we get the movement
for our tetromino
so that's the short very compact version
of how this game loop is going to work
and we also kind of have to look into
the future because we are going to check
the collision before we actually move
the player so when we make a move if it
drops or if you move it with the arrows
on your keyboard we first check the
collision before we make the move and if
it collides we don't make the move
because then we know that it has
collided we always check the game field
the stage one step ahead before we make
the move and that is also going to be
much more clear when we actually do this
coding I just wanted to explain it
shortly for you so you have a rough idea
of how this is going to work all right
so let's get back to our code we can
start in our hooks directory in our
hooks folder and inside of that folder
we create two new files we create one
that is called use player dot yes and
one that is cool
use stage EAS and as I said I always
named my files as the component or in
this case the hook itself and in react
you always name your custom hooks with
use before the actual name so in this
case it's you stage and use player so we
can start off in the use player JS file
so make sure you're inside of that file
and we import and we're not going to
need react for this one we just need to
use state state from react because this
is not a react component so we just
importing the you state then we can
import our random tetromino function and
we grab that from dot dot forward slash
tetrominoes then we export Const and we
have our use player as I said it's
important to have use before otherwise
react won't know that this is a custom
hook I have an error function curly
braces and we're going to create a state
for this one and that's the only thing
we're going to do in this video then
we're going to build more up on these
files in the next videos we're going to
create the state now with a hook that's
called you state that we imported up
here and you state will return an array
with two items in it for us and that's
where we can use es6 destructuring to
grab these two values so we have a Const
and we have an array that we want to the
structure and we can call it a player
and we have the set player and we use
state and this is the way that new state
works as I said we get two values back
we've got the actual state here and then
we have this sector for this state you
can call them whatever you want they
don't need to be player or set player
and this is just two values that weed
the structure out here so this line here
is actually short for all of this we
have a cost with layer state maybe and
we use state and then we
or player and we grab players state and
the first value in the array then we
have our set player and then we have our
player state and the second value in
that array but by using es6
destructuring we can make it in one
world here and that's very very
convenient and that's the way you should
do it when you do state so get rid of
this we are also going to set an initial
state for a player and you can actually
send in your initial state to the you
state when you create the state with it
we're going to have an object so we have
curly braces and inside we're going to
have a property that's called post
that's the position for a player we're
going to have an x value and we set that
to 0 and an Y value we set it to 0 also
and then we have our tetromino and
that's going to be one of them we
created down here that we are always
going to keep in this state for the
player and for now we can actually just
set the random tetromino so we call that
function and we're going to grab the
shape from the tetromino
and if you remember we had one shape
property and one color property so this
is the one we're grabbing here that's
the shape of our tetra mono zero equals
nothing and the letter inside of here
equals the cells that are occupied in
our tetromino
and i choose to have the letter of the
actual tetra mine here you can actually
have the same letter for every one of
them it doesn't matter because we're
just going to check if it's not 0 when
we render the tetra minor to the stage
alright so we grab a random tetra mono
and the shape of that one and put it in
our state for the player and then we're
going to have a property that's called
collided and we set that of false so
that's our initial state for the player
and now we're actually just going to
return the player because we're going to
import this custom hook into our Tetris
component and then we're going to need
the player inside of the Tetris
component I'm going to show you this in
a second
for now this is it for the use player
we're going to return to this file and
we can now move on to our u stage hook
and do almost the same for that one
so we import use state from react so we
import create stage from dot dot forward
slash game helpers alright and then we
create their custom hook
so we export Const and we're going to
call it use stage and it's an arrow
function curly braces and recreate the
state for this one also so we call it
stage and set stage and recall the u
stage hook and inside of this we're
actually going to give it the initial
stage and we can just call the create
stage inside of here and it will
generate the initial stage for us the
clean board for again as we have here so
that's of state for the stage and we're
going to return we're going to need both
the stage and the set stage for this one
so we return on a handle you can see
that I'll type u stage here it should of
course be used state like so so we save
this one and then we're going to do a
little bit of coding in our Tetris
component also so make sure you're
inside your Tetris J's file we can
actually remove the create stage for
this one now we just had it before we're
not going to need that one cause we're
creating the stage in ru stage hook now
so remove this one and we can actually
make a little comment here this is a
style components and then we're going to
have our custom hooks so we import use
player from node forward slash hooks and
use player and then we
to import or you stage from dot dot
forward slash hooks you stage alright
and we already have import to the
components we are going to use some
state in this component also so we have
to import you state up here alright so
we both importing react and your state
and now we can remove this console.log
but it would be nice to have a console
log here that tells us if it renders so
we can create that one console log we
render it's always nice to have now
we're going to create two states now
actually because yeah we're not going to
use them right now but we can create
them as we were already in this
component we're going to have one that's
called dot time and one that's called
game over and the drop time is the
actual speed that we're going to modify
depending on which level we're on and
then the game over is yet simply going
to tell us if the game is over or not so
we're keeping true or false in a state
for that one so we create the new state
that called drop time and set drop time
we have you state and for this one we
can just initialize it with null and we
have a game over and set game over and
ru state and we set that one to false of
course it's not game over when we start
and then we're going to use our custom
hooks and if you remember from a player
we exported or player and that means
that we can grab that one with
destruction here Const player and use
player like so and whatever stage and
for that one we exported to different
values in an array so we can distract
them out also so we have our stage and
or set stage
or custom hooked called you staged and
we send in the player to this one we're
not using the player in this custom hook
yet but we are going to need or play in
this one so we're going to modify this
to use the player later so that's why we
can send it in already no because we
have the player here so we send that one
in okay and then we can remove this one
because you're not needing that
functional we already have a stage in
our variable called stage that we get
from new stage so we use that one
instead here and we can actually also
use this game over variable here because
when the game is over we're going to
show a display that says it's over so
somewhere in the aside here we create
curly braces we checked our game over
variable if that's one is true we're
going to show a display component with a
prop of game over with sending that one
into the display component because if
you remember we're changing the color of
the text to read if it's game over so we
just simply sending the game over
variable and we have the text that
equals to game over and we self close
the component there this is a ternary
operator so if the game is not over
we're simply going to display everything
of this like so so if we have a game
over we just display this one that says
game over we don't display the score the
rules on the level and if the game is
not over we are displaying all of these
so we save the file and it seems to be
working
we didn't break anything in the game and
it's just complaining here because we're
not using these values yet but that's
fine in the next video we are going to
create the player movement with the keys
on the keyboard and we're going to do
the stage update we're actually not
seeing and a tetraman
now but we will see it in the next video
hopefully
okay let's create the movement for the
player and also the stage update so we
can see the changes take place on our
stage here first we're going to be
working in the tetris JS file the tetris
component and I'm actually going to take
back some code we deleted in the last
video we are going to use the create
stage function in this one also so
import it again sorry for that we import
create stage from dot forward slash game
helpers we're going to need this one
when we restart the game we need to
create a clean stage for that one so
we're going to need a few functions now
because we're going to create the
movement for the player so down below
here somewhere below the console log
re-render we are going to need a
function that's called move player and
it's going to take in a direction as a
parameter for now we just leave it empty
then we're going to need a function
that's called start game we leave it
empty for now we have another one that
we call drop and we leave that one empty
and we have another one that's called
dropped player yeah and that may seem
odd now that we have two similar
functions here but it will get clear to
you when we have more code in this
component and I'll explain why them and
the last one for now is a function
that's called move and we go into the
structure out the key code for this one
this is going to be the callback
function when we press the keys on the
keyboard all right we're going to fill
them with code in a second but first I'm
going to explain this style Tetris
wrapper for you
so we created this one with a width and
height of the complete window here and
that's because we need some way to take
our key inputs and this one the rapid
Eve here is going to be responsible for
that so it's going to have a few
Propst we need to set the role to button
otherwise it won't respond to the key
press and we need to have a tab index
that equals to zero and we have an on
key down and we go into call or function
that's called move for that one and send
in the event so that's why we have this
style Tetris wrapper it's some kind of
hell you don't see the deep here but it
will cover the complete screen here and
that's why when we for example click
here it will register the key presses
for us if we didn't have that one or for
example just put the key press on this
one you have to click on this to get the
key presses to register let's go to a
callback function that's called move
that's the one we call here first of all
we're going to check that the game isn't
game over because then we don't want to
register any key press so if parenthesis
and not game over then we can do
something here and then we check again
if or key code with the structure that
one out from our event because on our
event we have a property that's called
key code and if we destructor it here we
don't have to type e dot key code a
little win here because that's not too
long to write an e but yeah and we're
checking if the key code equals to 37
and that's the key code for the left
error on the keyboard then we're going
to move the player we call or move
player with the minus one because we're
moving to the left that's why it's minus
one if our key code equals 39 that's the
right arrow on the keyboard we're going
to move the player to the right and
that's why we have a 1 here so left
equals minus 1 because we're moving
minus 1 on the x axis and 1 equals right
because we're moving one step on the x
axis and then we have another LCF if the
key code equals to 40 that's the down
error on a keyboard
we dropped
because we pressing down so we wanted to
go down so that's a remove function and
in or drop player function for now we're
just going to call the drop so we're
just calling this one we're going to
have another little special case inside
of this later on so I'll explain that
them then we have our drop function and
we're going to create the function in or
use player hook that's called update
player pause and here yeah it will do
what it says it will update the player
position update player force and we're
going to give it an object with the x
value of zero and the y value of one
because we're dropping out and I can see
that I'm in the wrong function here so
just copy and paste that one inside it
should be in the drop function so as we
drop in here we're going to increase the
Y value of one and make the player
tetromino
go down and we set the collided to false
all right it will complain because we
aren't created this function yet and in
the start game function we can just make
a little comment here reset everything
and we set the stage to create stage we
call our function to create a new stage
and we reset the player and that's also
a function that's going to be in the use
player hook and the start game is a
callback function also that we're going
to have on our start button so we can
set an onclick handler and call the
start game function so what we'll do
when we press the start game button we
will reset the stage and we will also
reset the player and then we have a
removed player function and that one is
going to take care of the left and right
movement so we call the update player
process and we give it the x-value of
direction and the y-value of 0 because
now we're just moving left and right and
we're giving it a value here minus 1
or one alright we save that file and it
will break now of course because we
haven't created these ones yet so we
have to create the update player post
function and the reset player function
and we're going to place them in or use
player custom hook and that means that
when we call or use player function here
we also want to get the update player
posts and the reset player from that
custom hook alright so let's move into
our use player hook so make sure you in
the use player J's file and we're going
to continue write some code here we're
going to create these two functions here
so we have our update player force and
it's going to be a function that takes
in an object and we can the structure
out X Y and collided from that one and
we create an error function curly braces
and inside of here we're going to set
the state because now we're moving the
player so we can set the player state
here so we call set player that's the
one up here and we do that with an
update function if we do that we get the
previous state here and we have to have
a parentheses here because we just can't
give it the object because it will think
that these curly braces are for the
block and that's why we have the
parentheses here we spread our previous
state we set apostle to the new one we
have an X property so we set that one
two or previs dot X plus equals x then
we set a y-value previs dot y m+ equals
y so we're adding the values to our
state here and then we set our collided
property like so so that's the update
player position we just set in the state
with a new x and y values here and our
collided value alright then we need one
for reset play
so we create the cost reset player and
for this one we're actually going to
need a hook that's called use callback
and that's because otherwise our game
loop will go into an infinite loop we
won't see it now because we haven't
created one yet in or you staged hook
where we're going to use this function
but trust me we need to have the used
call back here otherwise we will be in a
mess with an infinite loop so we use
callback and give it an inline function
here it is going to be dependent on
nothing because we just create this once
so we set the player and in this case
we're resetting everything so we won't
need to have this update the function
here and give it a previous state
we can just set the state from scratch
so our position or post or X property we
set that to our stage width and we
divide it by two I subtract two also to
get it kind of in the middle because
this one will position the Tetra minor
in the stage so this one will give it
yeah kind of in the middle and we have
our Y property we set that one to zero
because we want or tetromino to be at
the top when we reset the player and we
have a tetra minor and we will give it a
random tetra minor and grab the shape so
each time we call this we will get the
random tetra minor and this is the way
that the tetra- change randomly and we
set collided to false like so we also
have to import the you scroll back up
here and use callback is a standard
react hook and the last thing we have to
do for now is also return or update
player position or update player posts
and or reset player and this should be
it now so it's still working
but nothing happens here because we're
not drawing anything to the stage now
and that's what we're going to be doing
now so let's go into our do stage
dot J's file or you staged custom hook
and this one is going to be a little
maybe complicated but I hope we will get
through it and that's the thing with
game making because as I said I'm not
the game maker so yeah some stuff can be
hard to understand when you're not a
game maker but even if you don't
understand everything that's game
specific I hope you will learn some
stuff in react okay so let's continue in
this one we're going to take in our
player and reset player as our
parameters for this one so add these
ones up here then we're going to use the
hook that's called use effect Nats one
is for creating side effects with react
and it's kind of a replacement for the
life cycle methods in the class
components I won't go into detail with
every hook here so you have to look up
that yourself if you don't know how use
affect works and what is for they have
an excellent the text on the react
homepage where you can read about all
the hooks alright so we create our use
effect and that one is going to have an
inline error function where we're going
to create everything for our effect and
this is the dependency array for now we
can just leave it empty we create
another function inside of here that's
called update stage we're going to give
it the prep stage the previous stage and
below here we're going to set the state
of the stage with this function so we
have the stage state here and we set it
with the set stage so set stage and then
we have our update function so we grab
the previous stage state it's easy to be
confused here with stage and state it's
almost the same saying that so we call
or update stage in our previous state
and you can also see that we're placing
this function inside of the use effect
and by doing this we don't have to
specify it as a dependency here so we
can have it inside of this effect all
right and now we have to do so
things here because when we update the
stage we first have to flush the stage
we have to kind of clear it from the
previous render so we create the Const
with a new stage we take a previous
stage of prep stage and we met through
it so we get our role and we have an
inline function here and we make another
map on a row because this is a
multi-dimensional array so we have to do
two maps here it will probably be a
little bit faster if we do this with
just four loops but I think we will be
fine here using map but if you care a
lot about performance you shouldn't use
map I think in a game like this you
should use the for loop because that
will be faster than the map all right so
we have a row we've mapped over a row
and then we get our cell and we're going
to return on new cell value and here
we're going to make use of the one I
talked about here where we create the
stage where we set it to clear or merged
so I'll show you that now we create the
Turner operator here we have a cell
value we check the value in our cell
array and I will go back to this again
to make it as clear as I can it's this
value here we're grabbing so we simply
check if that one is set to clear clear
then we are going to return an empty
cell so we return an array with a zero
and clear otherwise we are just going to
return the cell and this is what I've
been talking about before because if we
haven't marked our cell - merged then we
just swipe it out we just clear it and
we return a fresh clear cell here
otherwise we return the cell as it is
and it will stay in the stage so that's
the way we know what cells have collided
tetraman
in them or not so we have flushed the
stage here then draw the tetromino so we
flush the stage remove everything that
shouldn't be there and then we draw the
new stage for this render and we can do
that by loop through our tetra minor and
we have our tetra minor in our player if
we check or use player we created the
state here so we have the tetra Milo
here it's in the object for the player
and in our Tetris we are sending in the
player to the u stage and we getting it
here so that's why we can access the
player in a real stage custom hook so we
have our player and the tetra minor
property for each we're not going to
return a new one here we're just going
to simply loop through it we have a row
and we have Y value curly braces then
we're going to map through a row because
this one is also a multi-dimensional
array so it's unfortunately a lot of
loops here when doing this we have our
value and our x value for that one and
we have an array in line function it may
be a lot to grasp now when you just
typing it in like this so I suggest
again you stop and just try to really
understand what we're doing here because
now we're looping through or tetra minor
and now we're going to check which cells
in the tetra minor that are occupied and
that way we know the shape of the
tetromino we have our value here for a
tetra minor for our cell in the tetra
mono so we can check if the value isn't
0 then we know that we're on a cell that
makes up the shape of this tetra minor
and then we also know how we can
position the tetra minor on the stage we
have our new stage up here that we
flushed it's a fresh stage that we can
use to draw or tetra minor so we have a
new stage and yet
this is a multi-dimensional array so we
have to set the y and x value for this
one first we have a rose that's our Y
value so we have the Y value plus player
force dot y then we have our x value
plus layer force dot X this will give us
the coordinates on the stage so we are
going to set these ones to the value and
the value here remember that it's the
tetromino that we looping through so we
get the value of the tetromino and in
this case it's going to be yeah one of
these values here let's go back to our u
stage so that's of value and then we're
going to do back ticks here two of them
and inside we have a dollar sign in
curly braces because we're going to
check with the Turner operator if our
player is collided then we set this one
to merged otherwise we set it to clear
and this is yet again how we know that
we should clear this tetromino
in the next render if we set it too much
we know it has collided and this one
when we flush the stage before we do
this it will be set to merged and that
way we know that we should keep it in
the stage because it has collided
otherwise it's set to clear and then we
can just delete it in the next render
before we do anything else all right
this is beginning to be a long video
sorry for that but we have to do this
and inside our function here make sure
you're in the right scope here inside or
update stage function we are returning
the new stage for now because we're not
checking any collisions yet we're going
to return to this one and as you can see
here when I order for married this one
it has filled in this itself these are
the dependencies that we need for this
use effect so we have the play not
collided the plane or post attacks
player dot postdoc Y and player dot
tetromino
we're using them inside of this use
effect and that's why we have to specify
them as dependencies here and we are
going to use the reset player that we
wrapped in our use call back later so
that's why we have wrapped it because
we're going to add it as a dependency to
this one and it's this use effect that
will go into an infinite loop if we
don't wrap it in a use call back
alright save this one and as you can see
we have a tetra minor here now and
that's great and if we reload this one
we get a different tetra mono because we
have randomized them and that's working
great and is this working
no okay let's check that out in our tab
trees all right I see here it shouldn't
be unclick it should be called back
because if we look in our Start button
we have the prop here that's called call
back so make sure you're in the Tetris
component and change this one to call
back and I bet it will work now and it
does and I think I saw a little bug
there yeah it disappears and I think it
is it's probably when we get the same
tetromino as before and I think that is
if we go into the youth stage custom
hook we have these dependencies here so
when we get the exact same tetra mono it
won't rerender because this one is
dependent of the collider the position X
the position Y and the tetra mono so
they are going to be the exact same in
the next render if we get the same tetra
mono and that's not good
I think we can just change the
dependency to player and save this one
make sure you reload it
it's working great now I don't think
this will give us any trouble in the
future so I haven't seen this bug
actually before I think it had gone
through everything but yeah that's the
thing with code you always get surprised
I think it will be fine to have the
player there otherwise we'll change it
later and I also saw some little other
stuff here we have to adjust because
when you start the game you don't want
this one to show up here before we have
pushed the start button and that's why I
created in this file tetra- I created
this zero here with just a blank little
cell here and that's the one we're going
to use for this now so if we go back
into our use stage now into our news
player you can see that we are just
rendering a random tetromino here and
that's not good if we import our tetra-
also here then we can just grab the
tetra mono and we grab the first one in
the array tetra minor
tetra - and we save it and as you can
see now the stage is blank here and
that's good and if we push the start it
will generate a random tetromino for us
to start with and of course also we have
created the movement for this one so if
you press left and right and the down
button we can actually move the tetra
minor now and as you can see we have not
done any collision detection yet so it
will screw up here but that's fine for
now we will fix that later but at least
the controls are working and that's also
great so we have something here now we
are getting somewhere and we will
continue this one in the next video
it's time to create some collision
detection now for our game because now
it isn't working here we can move
outside the play field and it looks kind
of screwed up here and that's not what
we want so let's go back into our code
and we're going to be working in the
game helpers J is file for now that's
where we're going to place the collision
detection function it made sense for me
to place it in that file but if you feel
that you want to place it somewhere else
you can do that of course but for this
tutorial I'm going to create it here so
make sure you in the game helpers dot JS
file and we have to think about a few
things before we create this function
one of them is that it's probably better
to use for loops because it will be at
least a little bit faster than to use
for example map or for each because we
are going to loop through or tetra minor
here again and we're going to have two
loops for this one also so if we use for
example for each we can't break out of
that one and that's the downside for us
because we want to break out of the loop
as soon as we collide with anything so
feel free if you want to experiment with
this and try different ways of doing it
I'm going to use for loops so we can
start by creating or function now we
need to export this one because we're
using it in the components so we need to
have an export Const and we call it
check collision we give it a player the
stage and we give it an object where we
can the structure out the move X and the
move Y so what I'm doing here is that I
rename the X and y to move X and to move
Y and that's because I'm going to use Y
and X in my loops so I want to have a
different name for these parameters here
and it's an error function and we have
curly braces so we're going to loop
through or tetromino in this one so we
have a for loop let y equal 0 and Y
should be less than player tetromino dot
length and then we just have the one
plus equals one for each iteration and
then in sorry we have another loop let X
equal zero and X should be less than
player dot tetromino and we can grab the
Y value dot length and then we have the
X plus equals one so we add one to this
one for each iteration also and we could
of course just say zero here because it
doesn't matter which row we are checking
a length of course the rows are the same
length all right so what do we have to
do here now first of all this is the
tetromino we're looping through and we
first have to check that we are actually
on a tetra- cell and the 0 don't make up
the shape of the actual tetromino so we
have to check that the cell isn't 0 so
we can make some comments here 1 check
that we're on an actual tetra- cell like
so and then we create an if statement
and we check if player docked at romano
and now we're grabbing a y-value and or
x value from our loops and it shouldn't
equal 0 right so that way we know that
we're actually on a cell that make up
the shape for the tetromino and we
should check that cell if it collide
with anything
so what collisions do we have to check
we make a little comment here again we
need to check that our movement is
inside of the game areas height that
we're not moving the tetromino outside
of the bottom of the stage so we can
just make a comment check that or move
is inside the game areas height and we
can now set Y in parentheses and maybe
also we shouldn't go through the bottom
of the play area alright and we can
actually
specify the other things we're going to
check before we create them so down
below here create number three then we
need to check that our tetra mono isn't
moving outside of the game areas width
check that or move is inside the game
areas width and that's an X and then
below here we have the fourth thing
we're going to check and that is we're
going to check that the cell isn't set
to clear because this function will
return true or false if it returned true
we have obviously collided with
something otherwise it's false and we
haven't collided with something so if
the cell is set to clear then we know
that we're not colliding with anything
and it will return false
check that the cell we're moving to
isn't set to clear because if it is
clear we're not colliding all right so
that's of things we have to check here
we're going to do this with ashamed
short-circuit
whoa that was hard for me to say as I'm
not natively speaking English you
probably can hear that also but you have
to live with it so if not staged and we
grab the Y value plus player dot post
dot y plus or move why we're looking
into the future here you can always say
like that because we're checking here if
the position that we intend to move to
is colliding so here we simply checking
that our stages Y value actually has a
value in it if it doesn't have that we
know that we are outside the bottom of
the stage and this will also return true
because we're setting this to not with
this exclamation mark so if it not find
anything here in this stage row it will
return true and we know that we are
colliding with something and as I said
we do a short circuit here so we do on
or I actually don't know what these
signs are called in English it's design
for or in a short circuit okay then we
need to check that our move is inside
the game errors width so we have the
exclamation mark we're checking that not
why plus layer dot post dot y plus move
Y and then we need to check the actual
cell here so we check the X plus player
dot post dot X plus move X and here it
is complaining here cuz we of course
need an if statement here also so wrap
this in an if statement return true and
we go back to this one we create another
or am I going to do or fourth check here
okay the fourth one we're going to check
I misspell this check we are going to
check if this cell is not set to clear
and we can do that by typing stage and
then we do the same thing here y plus
player dot pause y plus move Y and then
we have the cell so we have X plus
player Foss dot X plus move X and then
it's the second one in this array that
we have to check so we type in a one
here and we check that it isn't cleared
like so and this one should of course be
a capital y so here you have it that's
everything we need for our child of
simple collision detection I'll actually
almost copy and paste this code from the
math math method tutorial because I
think this is a very simple and clever
way to check the collision because with
this collision detection we can detect
if we're outside a stage and also if we
collide with any of the tetriminos
because we're looping through the Tetra
minor that we have in play and check if
any of the cells inside of that
tetrominoes collide with any of the
cells in the play field and that's how
this function gets checked for
everything that we want if we go outside
the stage and also if we collide with
another tetra minor that's merged to the
stage so we save it and we see that we
didn't break anything and we
didn't do that and that's good we have
to go inside or use stage hook and add a
little collision detection here because
when we have the new stage here with the
new updated position we then check check
if we collided like so so you can do a
little if statement here if player dot
collided then we just reset the player
like so and it will need a new
dependency here so we can add recept
player because if we collide we just
reset the player we move the player up
to the zero Y position and the other one
will stay in place where we collided
because we merge it into the stage here
the last thing we have to do here now is
to go into our Tetris component and
actually use our sheykh collision
function first we have to import it from
the game help us
so we have our Czech collision import it
there and we have to check the collision
when we move the player and when the
player drops so inside or move player we
create an if statement and if we don't
collide we send in the player the stage
and the intended position we want to
move to so we have an X value of
direction and we have the Y set to zero
because this move player function is
responsible for moving the player left
and right so yeah I probably should have
named it something else yeah I realize
that so you can change it to a more
descriptive name if you want to do that
then we can move this one inside of the
if statement and this means that if
we're not colliding with with anything
we actually do the move otherwise we
don't do anything here so we save it and
we can see if it works we shouldn't be
able to go outside the play field to the
left and to the right and we can't and
that's great
so it will stop the Tetra monolayer
because we are colliding with the sides
of the stage
then we have to check for collision when
we drop the player so inside of the drop
function we do almost the same here
we check if not check collision we give
it the player the stage and the intended
move so we have the x value in this case
it's zero and it's the y value that
we're going to give of 1 because we're
moving one step down each at a time and
we can move this one up here inside of
the if statement in this case we're
going to have an else also in this case
as we drop in we know that if we collide
on something when we drop we also need
to set the collided property to true in
the player and that's because if we
collide with something when we drop we
know that this tetra- should be merged
to the stage because it can't drop
anymore so we we need to yeah merge it
into the stage so we update player force
we give it an x value of 0 and a y-value
of 0 we're not moving anymore with
you're setting the collided to true we
can also inside of this else block
create something when the game is over
because if we're colliding and the
player dot force dot y is less than 1 we
know that we're colliding up here
somewhere and the game should be set to
game over so we can console log game
over and then we're going to set game
over to true and set drop time to no
because we're not dropping any more so
we set that a null and also up here in
the start game function we can set game
over to false because we're starting a
new game here so it shouldn't be set to
true all right we save it and see what
we've got
we're checking here and it's still
working with a collision on the sides
and if we go down here it should merge
into that position in the stage and
thus that's great and we can see if it
will go into game over mode here when we
are colliding at the top and it does
also and that's really really sweet but
now we have a kind of half working game
it's not dropping because we haven't
created it in the world and we can't
rotate the player so that's what we're
going to do in the next videos
in this video we're going to create the
rotation for the player and we're mostly
going to be in the use player custom
hook so make sure you're in the use
player custom hook we're going to create
two new functions in this one so just
below our state here we can create one
that's called rotate this one is going
to receive a matrix and a direction so
the matrix is actually going to be or
tetromino so you can name it to that
also if you want and of course we're
going to have an equal sign and an arrow
here then we're going to have another
function that's called play rotate and
we could actually do them in one
function but I wanted to separate them
out because the rotate here actually do
the rotation and the play rotate are
going to do some other things also
because we need to check the collision
here when we rotate the Tetra minor
that's why I separate them into two
functions so we have the cost play
rotate equals it is going to take in the
stage and direction and we create an
arrow function and as I said before you
can of course create regular functions
if you want it's just me that yeah I
like to create arrow functions instead
but if it makes more sense for you to
create a regular function you can do
that also it doesn't matter here okay so
first we create a rotate function and
that's the one that's going to take in
the Tetra minor and the direction and we
want to rotate the Tetra minor and how
can we rotate the Tetra minor yeah first
of all we can make all the rows to
become columns instead so we kind of
shift them in the array and that way all
the rows are going to be columns instead
and then if we reverse all of the values
in the rows we get the rotation so that
is how this is going to work so first
make the rose to become calls now we can
call it this transpose okay we create a
new Coast we can call it rotate the
tetra all right so we take our matrix we
mapped
that one we're not going to use the
actual value in this loop but we need
the index then we map through the matrix
again and we have the column and we
return the call and the index and this
one will make all the rows in the array
to become columns so that's the first
step in rotating then we need to reverse
each row to get a rotated matrix or a
tetromino in this case and this one we
have to separate into two things because
it depends on which direction we are
moving how we do this if we move with
the direction of value that's bigger
than zero we know that we're moving kind
of clockwise then we need to reverse all
of the rows to get the rotation right
otherwise if we move in the other
direction if it's for example minus one
it's less than zero then we just reverse
the complete matrix or in this case the
rotated Tetro as we call it I know that
this can seem a little bit too much and
I think this is one of the thing again
with game making you do this stuff all
the time when you rotate things I
actually had to think about this twice
or three or four times before I got it
myself and he explained it quite good in
the math math methods video on how he
rotate things I don't do it exactly the
same here in this function but the
principle is the same
we have transposed or array or matrix or
tetromino and we have converted all or
rows into columns and we save them in
the rotated Tetro then we can check if
the direction is bigger than 0 we return
or rotated the Tetra that we're going to
map and we have the row and all of the
rows are going to be reversed for this
one so we use the reverse function on
this row and that's a built-in function
in JavaScript
otherwise we're moving in the other
direction so we can just return the
rotated petrol dot reverse okay now we
can create or play rotate where we're
also going to do some collision
detection when we rotate the player and
I'm going to show you why in a second
but first as always we don't want to
mutate or state or anything so we create
a copy of our player we can call it
cloned player we cannot do a shallow
copy here so we need to make kind of a
deep clone and you can do that with
Jason dot force and JSON dot stringify
layer so now we get a complete copy a
complete clone of our player and that's
good we don't have to work with the
player that's in the state because we
shouldn't mutate the state then we take
a cloned layer and grab the tetromino
from that one and we use a rotate
function and we rotate the cloned layer
dot tetromino
and we give it the direction also and
this will rotate the player and we can
set the player to the cloned player we
also need to export our functions here
or actually it's just a player rotate we
need to export we will get back to this
in a second but first we have to
actually create the rotation in the
tetris component first of all we need to
add the player rotate here so we get it
inside our tetris component from the use
player we're also returning this one
then below here in our move function
where we check the key code on what key
is pressed and call a function we also
need to add another elsif here
so if the keycode equals to 38 that's
the up error on the keyboard we call
play rotate give it the stage and one
because we are going to need a stage
when we do the collision detection in a
minute and this is the direction we're
sending in so we're rotating it
clockwise and this means that we have a
functional that we can rotate
counterclockwise also so if you want you
can add another key here that will
rotate the Tetra minor in the opposite
direction that's very easy to implement
if you want to do that I kind of play
Tetris with just rotating it with one
key so I choose to not implement two
keys for rotating in different
directions here all right let's see if
this works and it does that's nice but
if we go to this side here you can see
if we rotate it it will rotate outside
of the stage and that's no good and it
will break it as you see here but it's
rotating nicely we're going to fix this
thing now so it can't rotate outside of
the stage so go back into our code and
inside our use player custom hook and
inside the player rotate function we're
going to continue write some code here
that will solve this problem for us and
this one I actually grabbed it directly
from the math math method tutorial cause
I think it's very clever how he does
this so this code is straight from that
one first we want to save or position in
a Const so we have composts equals
cloned player dot post dot X so that's
the x position we save here then we're
going to create a new left that we call
offset and that equals 1 then we're
going to have a while loop so we have
while and inside a while we check
collision we send in the clone player
the stage
we're not moving it anywhere so we just
give it zero values in this object here
with the X&Y we already import to the
shack coalition up here so we don't have
to do that again and now we're going to
write some tricky code here actually and
I'll try to explain it for you if we go
back into our game and try to show you
here so let's just place a few of the
tetra- here and I try to explain it if
we rotate this one here as you can see
it will move inside of these tetra- and
that's no good and this little function
we're going to write now is going to
take wait I'm going to create another
one here it's going to take the Tetra
minor when we rotate it and move it
right and left and right and left and
check if we collide with something and
that's the clever little function that
he came up with in that tutorial let's
say we go right it will check or we
colliding no then we go left or we
colliding there no and then it will
continue until we collide or if we don't
collide we can actually rotate the
player so that is how this is going to
work in this while loop so we have our
clone player we set the position dot x +
equals the offset and this is how we
keep track on how many steps we're
moving to the side back and forth so we
set the offset it equals to minus
parenthesis offset plus the offset if
it's greater than zero we set it to 1
otherwise we set it to minus 1 and it's
this little row here that will create
the kind of back and forth movement for
us with the tetromino
then we can create an if statement and
we check if the offset is greater than
clone player dot tetromino
and we grab the first value in the array
and length here we're just grabbing the
first row and check the length of that
one we don't need to do any more check
here because we have looked through the
complete length of the taproom
then we just rotate the Tetra minor back
because this move isn't allowed we can't
rotate it if we have tried this back and
forth more than the width of the Tetra
minor then we know that we can't rotate
so we just rotate it back because we
already rotated it up here so we just
rotate it back rotate loan player dot
tetromino and minus direction we reverse
the direction so we rotate it back every
septic loan player dot post dot X 2
equals position and that's the one we
set up here because we want it to have
the same position as we had from the
beginning and then we just return so
this is see a quite a handful of a
function I don't blame you if you don't
get it especially this one it can seem a
little bit tricky it took some thinking
for me to understand this just think of
it as this one will go back and forth
and see if it collide with something
when we rotate and if we do we can't
rotate it that way and it will
constantly move it away from that one
when we rotate so we can save it and see
if it works we can try this out if we
rotate it now you can see that it kind
of pops out from the wall it won't go
through it and also if we do some
rotating here it can't rotate through
them and that's good
so I actually think that this is the
most advanced function in this tutorial
because this is quite advanced don't
blame yourself if you don't get it the
first time just try out yourself try to
change the code try to look at it read
it try and change it again and you will
soon get it how it works if you don't
get it right away and if you get it
right away well good for you and see you
in the next video
okay we have a kind of a functioning
tetris game here just a few things left
to do if we take a look here we see that
we have some full rows here and they
should be swept off the stage and it
should give us some score at the end but
it won't do that now because yeah we can
just fill this up and nothing will
happen in this video we will create the
function that will kind of sweep the
stage and see if there's any rows that
needs to be cleared and also push down
the other ones that shouldn't be cleared
so that said go into our code again and
into our u stage custom hook inside of
this custom hook we first going to
create another state so we create a
state here that's called rows cleared
and set rows cleared and this is how
we're going to keep track of all the
rows that we have cleared so we use
state and give it an initial value of 0
okay and the first thing we want to do
in this use effect is to set rows
cleared to 0 then we're going to create
another function here that's called
sweep rows we're going to give it a new
stage to sweep and it's going to be an
implicit return for this one so we don't
have to have curly braces we grab a new
stage and we're going to do some
reducing here so reduce this is the
built-in reduce es6 function we have the
accumulator at the row arrow function
curly braces so we give this function a
stage and we're going to map through it
with reduce so we do that with new stage
reduce and we get the row and
accumulator if you don't know how reduce
works I suggest you look it up and the
first thing we have to do now is to
check if our row just contains cells
that are merged and that means that we
can check
if a row don't contain zeros and we can
do that we'd find index so if row find
index we have our cell and an inline
function we check if the first value in
our cell array equals to zero and if
this one equals to minus one we know
that we haven't found a value of zero
and then we know that this is a full row
and should be clear because fine index
will return minus one if it don't find a
match with the provided function inside
of it if we're looking for the value
zero and it won't find that one then it
will return minus one and then we know
that this role should be swept away from
the stage so we first set rows cleared
and we do that with an update the
function because we're going to need the
previous value and we just add one to
that one then we're going to grab the
accumulator that's the new array we're
building up inside of this reduced
function we're going to unshift an
unshift let us add a new value to the
array at the beginning of the array
because if we look here if we for
example remove these three rows here we
need to add three rows at the top and we
can do that with the unshift method so
we remove these three ones here and if
we add three empty ones up here it will
push down the other ones and it will try
to create the illusion that this one's
just yeah
pop out of the stage and disappear so
with on shift we can add a complete
empty row at the beginning of the array
so we create a new array from our new
stage zero dot length that will give us
the width of the actual play field and
we fill it up with an array of zeros and
clear because these ones are completely
fresh so this should be a zero and clear
then for each iteration inside our
reduced we have to return the
accumulator also and this is if we find
a matching row
that should be cleared if we don't do
that we just push the row into the
accumulated array and we return the
accumulator again like this and we could
also give it an empty array to start
with so this is the complete function
here I will go through it again and tell
you what it will do we give this
function or stage and we take the
complete stage and use the reduce method
on this one
by using reduce we can create a new
array so we check if the row contains
any zero if it does we know that this
row shouldn't be clear because we
haven't filled up a complete row but if
we have filled up a complete row we
first add a row to a rows cleared state
then we add an empty a complete empty a
new row at the top of the array and we
return the accumulated array this works
because we completely ignored to return
the full row that we should remove from
the stage and instead we return a new
empty row at the top of the array so
this will create the illusion that we
remove the row on the stage and move the
other ones down that was above that row
and if we don't have a full row we just
return the row as as it is in the array
and that's the way it works we have to
use this function somewhere and we can
do it if we know that we collide with
something we should do this sweep and
see if we also have a full row so below
the reset player and because this one
returns a complete new stage we also
need to return the function and give it
the new stage so this one will take or
stage we create here when we have done
all the mapping with the tetromino and
everything and if it collides then we
call the sweep rows with this stage and
this one in turn will return another
stage for us when it has swept all the
rows and check that there is no full row
that needs to be removed from the stage
okay so we'll see if it works I have to
do some gaming here to get a full row
and that's nice to be able to play some
game here let's see if it works and it
does nice it's kind of easy now when
it's not dropping yeah and we know that
it works now so I don't have to create
another row here and we actually forgot
to do something here and go back into
our code and interview stage custom hook
we also need to return or rows cleared
because we're going to use this one in
the Tetris component later on so make
sure you add that one to the return
statement here alright so that's it
we'll continue by creating the interval
for the petrol miners to drop by
themselves in the next video
we are going to set this game in motion
and I think it's better we take a look
at Dan Abramov site first overacted dot
IO and then he has a blog post that's
called making setting develop
declarative with react hooks and it's 16
minutes read so I won't go through it
here but I suggest you read this one
because here he explained why it isn't a
good idea to just use set interval with
react hooks so he has created this
custom hook
that's called use interval that we are
going to use and hopefully you copy this
file over to your project folder as I
showed you in the beginning of this
tutorial
here's all the answers to why setting
the world is not good to use as it is we
dragged hooks it's better to create a
custom hook and use that one instead and
one thing Y is not so great is because
react hooks are heavily using closures
and closures can be quite difficult to
grasp if you're not that used to them he
has created this use in well for us that
we can just use in our game and that's
what we're going to do now so back to
our app and our code inside of our
Tetris component we're going to be in
that component in this video at the
beginning here where we import our
custom hooks we can import our use in a
well from dot dot forward slash hooks
and use in eval and that makes sure that
we can use this one inside of our
component ok and now we're going to make
this one move by itself because now we
can just drop it by pressing the down
key on our keyboard and that's no good
we want it to move by itself so we can
set up this interval and below I think
yeah here somewhere we can use our
interval so use in a well and this one
will take an inline function so we
create an error function and we are
going to call the drop function as we
created up here because that's the one
that makes the tetrominoes drop
so we call that one and we can specify
the interval timing here and we already
have a state that's called drop time so
we just send this one in to the use in a
well because if we look at the use in
eval it will take a callback and a delay
and the callback is the inline function
we created and the delay is our drop
time so that's how this works and also
if we set null into the drop time it
will stop and clear the interval so
that's good for us because that way we
can control the interval all right back
to the tetris component we have to do a
few more things here to get it up and
running because now our drop time is set
to null we set it up here so now the
interval is not active but we have a
start button so when we start our game
we can set our drop time and we send in
thousand that means one second and we
save it and then if we press start game
as you can see it's moving really good
here now and that's nice because now we
have a working Tetris game
great I want to do a few optimizations
here also we created one extra function
here that's called drop player inside
now we just call him drop and that's
when we press the down key on our
keyboard I want to stop the interval
when the player moves the Tetra minor
down with the keyboard and that's easy
we can just set the drop time to null
and that will make sure that we stop the
interval but we also have to activate it
again when the play releases the down
key so we're going to create a new
function here that's called key up and
inside of these we're going to take in
the key code again so with the structure
that out from our event and yet again
we're going to check if the game is not
game over and we can activate the
interval again when the player release
the down key so inside of here we check
if the key code equals 240 that is the
down key we will only run this if the
player is releasing the down key then we
set the drop time for now we just set it
to thousand again we are going to create
different speeds here later in the next
video so that's a callback function for
our key up event and we also have to
make sure that we have this event here
and we can create it on our style Tetris
wrapper so we just add on key up and it
equals key up and a little nice
formatting here and we save this one and
we can actually do a little console
logging here because here we can
console.log in the off and we copy this
one and go to
yup console on interval on make sure
you're showing your console here whoops
I misspell this one yeah my formatting
here has added this one for us yeah
that's nice so I can remove this one it
should only be used in eval here okay
so we start the game and I press the
down button you can see that in eval off
and then in eval on when we release the
button and that's great because then it
will not interfere with the keyboard
when we hold the key down it will repeat
itself and make the Tetra miner go down
faster and that could mess things up for
us if the interval also is activated
them so that's actually all there is to
it to create this movement this kind of
game loop that makes the Tetra mono drop
by itself in the next video I'm going to
conclude this tutorial and we create
some nice little displays here with
score and rows and level and we're going
to do that by create our last custom
hooked
we're almost finished now we're just
going to create our custom hook for
displaying scores rows and levels and we
are eventually going to import it here
in the Tetris component with the other
hooks here but we will create it first
so we have something to import here so
inside our hooks folder create a new
file that's called use game status doc
yes are we going to need a few things
here so we import you stay
use effect and use call back from react
then we export post use game status and
we're going to need one parameter here
that's called rows cleared that's the
one we created in our youth stage we're
going to send this one in to a use game
status because we need it when we
calculate our score and set the total
rows that we cleared because this one
here is just the rows that we cleared in
the current render that's why we set it
to zero here so we clear it on each
render and then we're going to send this
one in to the use game status where we
can add it up to the rows we already
have cleared before all right we have an
error function and curly braces and then
we're going to create three states here
so we have a cost with the structure out
score set score equals you stayed and we
have a zero you can just copy this one
paste it two times and we're going to
call this one rose and set Rose ever
going to initialize all of these with a
zero and we have our level and/or set
level so there you have it three states
then we going to need a cost that's
called line points and this is going to
be an array with 40 hundred three
hundred and twelve hundred and these are
the actual scores I
did some googling and found the scores
from the original tetris game so we're
going to use these to calculate or total
score I don't know there's probably a
lot of different versions so I don't
know if this is legit that it's truly
the original scores that we used and
also the formula for calculating the
score but I found this one I think it
was on Wikipedia actually so you can
have what scoring you want here if you
want to change it so we have a cost
that's called calc score and this is a
function we're creating here because
we're going to call this function in a
use effect and we also going to need a
use callback because otherwise this will
go into an infinite loop and that's no
good and I think that's also not a
problem but I think it can be annoying
because it's easy with react books to
make them go into an infinite loop if
you don't think about that very very
thoroughly
okay so first we're going to check if we
have score if Rose cleared is greater
than zero that means if we cleared any
rows in the render that's the one with
Sun in here because if it's zero
we didn't clear any row so don't have
any score calculations to do and that
means that if this one is greater than
zero we know that we cleared some rows
and we're going to calculate the score
and if it's zero yeah we know that we
didn't hear any rows in this render and
we don't need to calculate any score we
are going to calculate a score and set
our total rows so I create the comment
here this is how original Tetra score is
calculated so this is the formula I use
I found that one on the internet and I'm
using that here to calculate the score
so we just set our score state set score
we have a previous state and we use that
previous state to add something to it
and here's the formula we have the line
points that's the array up here and this
line points array have four different
values here and they each represent one
row cleared two rows
three heroes cleared and four rows
cleared and this is an array so the
index starts at zero so we have to take
a rose clear minus one because say for
example that we cleared two rows we need
to grab the value with index one in our
array and we're going to multiply that
with or level plus one and that's also
because our level starts at zero so
that's why we're adding one here so this
is the formula to calculate a score and
then we also need to set our rows where
our previous stayed here and we take the
previous state and add the new rows
cleared to that one and that will always
keep track of our total rows that we
cleared all right and as this is a used
cool back we have to make it depend on
something so we have the dependency
array here we have the level the line
points and the rows cleared so this one
is always going to change when the level
line points or rows cleared or changing
otherwise it will stay the same and
that's why it won't go into an infinite
loop because if we didn't have this used
callback it will change every render and
that will create the infinity loop okay
and then we create a use affect we want
this to fire off automatically and this
dependency array is going to depend on
the calculate score the rows cleared and
the score we just calling the calc score
here and as we using these ones in this
function we have to specify them as
dependencies here but then we have to
return something from this custom hooked
so there's a lot of things we're going
to return e we want to score we want a
set score because we want to reset the
score when we start a new game we need
two rows and we also need a set rows we
want to set the rows to zero when we
start a new game and also the same with
the level so
want a level and the set level like so
so we save this one and go back into our
Tetris component we import it where we
import our other custom looks use game
status from dot forward slash cooks use
game status all right then we have to
use this values inside of a Tetris
component but first we have to call or
use game status hooked we can do that
below here so we have a Const and we are
going to receive everything that we
returned from this one all of these here
we're going to receive here so we have
to specify them we have the score set
score rose set rose level and set level
and we're going to call or use game
status and we're sending in the rose
cleared as we talked about before and of
course we also have to grab the Rose
cleared here from our youth stage hook
see if I can make it a little bigger
here I think we actually can move this
one down here to make it a little nicer
looking like so okay and now we have to
use these values inside of our tetris
component first in our drop function we
want to change the level depending on
how many rows we have cleared and that
means we have to have something here
that calculates that on every drop so I
make a little comment here increase
level one player has cleared ten rows I
think that that also is the original
Tetris but I'm not sure when you clear
ten rows then we go up a level and the
speed will increase we create a little
if statement here we check if the rows
are greater than
level +1 that's because the level starts
at zero just as before times 10 we set
the level with our previous state and we
just have the previous plus 1 we just
increasing the level by 1 and we also
want to increase the speed and this
little formula I created here I don't
know if it's optimal actually I'm going
to set the drop time like so and then I
have thousand that's one second I divide
it with the level plus one and then I
just added 200 here so it will not get
too fast
and you can actually play with this and
try another formula and see if it works
better for you so I don't know if it's
good I think yeah it's working fairly
nice but yeah probably there will be a
better formula for this to use so that's
how we calculate our level we can
actually also set a few things here when
we start again because we also want to
reset our score level and rows so we can
set our score to 0 set rows to 0 and we
set our level to 0 when there's one more
thing we have to do here we are going to
take this formula here and copy that in
the drop function where we set the drop
time we have to also paste that in our
key up function because now we're just
setting it two thousand here so just
paste it in there and we want to display
or score rows and levels also so we can
change these ones inside other probes
we're sending in to the display
components to recreate curly braces
double ticks and we have our score and a
dollar sign and curly braces and we grab
our score then we do the same with the
rows and the levels we can copy this one
paste
and then we change this once we have a
rose and we have our level so this will
make sure that we display the score rose
and level and I think it's time to say
this one and see if it works so it's
already displaying the series here so we
can start the game
and it seems to be working nice so
that's it we have a working Tetris game
I just want to make a little
optimization here and I'm going to show
you why because if we go inside our cell
component and for now I have to do like
this because I want to console.log
something out we render so what I'm
doing here I'm just going to transfer
logout rerender on each cell here so I
save this one and as you can see we have
240 around us here and that's fine when
we build this table for the first time
but as you can see on each little drop
here now on each rotation and everything
we get 240 renders it probably won't be
an issue here because react is fast but
I want to show you here how you can
create a little optimization for this
one so we go back inside our cell
component and where we export this one
we're going to export it with react memo
and this will make sure that it
memorizes this cell component and only
remembers when the cells actually are
changing so we save this one and as you
can see we just remembering the cells
that actually change with the Tetra
minor now and I actually think that this
is a really good example to show you
what react memo does in react because
now it won't affect the cells that won't
change on that render it will only
remember the cells that change with the
tetromino and that's good
so we made quite an optimization here
and reduce the renders here and that's
good there you have it this is my this
is my version of Tetris with react hooks
and as I said a couple of times now I am
NOT a game developer but it was sure fun
to create this game and I think it's a
good practice in react and especially
react hooks to see how they work and I
hope you enjoyed this one as much as I
did and I'm
grateful that you have followed me on
this tutorial and I hope you learn a lot
I initially created this one exclusively
for free code camp and I actually record
a lot of free stuff especially in react
and fronting and stuff like that in my
own YouTube channel so if we go to
youtube and just search for vibe on 5w e
ib e-m-f ALK you will see my pretty face
here and you can just go to my channel
and make sure you subscribe if you want
free coding tips in react and other
front-end stuff and i also create paid
premium courses i'm going to move them
to my own platform soon but for now
they're up on udemy and it's a beginner
react course and also course in Gatsby
and how to create get besides with
WordPress as a headless CMS this also
free course on react Redux and this of
course the hooks introduction course
that were published on free code camp a
little while ago
and I'm also on Twitter just hooked me
up there if you have any questions or
just want to follow me there and I sure
appreciate the support I can get from
you I want to continue to create free
stuff and do things like this so
hopefully you'll see me again in another
video but for now thank you and goodbye